you've all been in a bar right but have
you ever gone to a bar and come out with
a two hundred million dollar business
that's what happened to us about ten
years ago we'd had a terrible day we had
this huge client that was killing us
we're a software consulting firm and we
couldn't find a very specific
programming skill to help this client
deploy a cutting-edge cloud system we
have a bunch of engineers but none of
them could please this client and we're
about to be fired so we go out to the
bar and we're hanging out with our
bartender friend Jeff and he's doing
what all good bartenders do he's
commiserating with us making us feel
better
relating to our pain saying hey these
guys are over blowing it don't worry
about it and finally he deadpans us and
says why don't you send me in there I
can figure it out so the next morning
we're hanging out in our team meeting
and we're all a little hazy and I half
jokingly throw it out there I say hey I
mean we're bout to be fired so I say why
don't we send you Jeff the bartender
there's some silence some quizzical
looks finally my chief of staff says
that is a great idea
Jeff is wicked smart he's brilliant
he'll figure it out let's send him in
there now Jeff was not a programmer in
fact he had dropped out of pen as a
philosophy major but he was brilliant
and he could go deep on topics and we
were about to be fired so we sent him in
after a couple of days of suspense Jeff
was still there they hadn't sent him
home I couldn't believe it what was he
doing here's what I learned he had
completely disarmed their fixation on
the programming skill and he had changed
the conversation even changing what we
were building the conversation was now
about what we were gonna build and why
and yes Jeff figured out how to program
the solution and the client became one
of our best references back then we were
200 people and half of our company was
made up of computer science majors or
engineers but our experience with Jeff
left us wondering could we repeat this
through our business so we changed the
way we recruited and trained and while
we still sought after computer engineers
and computer science majors we sprinkled
in artists musicians writers and Jeff's
story started to multiply itself
throughout our company our chief
technology officer is an English major
and he was a bike messenger in Manhattan
and today were a thousand people yet
still less than a hundred have degrees
in computer science or engineering
and yes we're still a computer
consulting firm we're the number one
player in our market we work with a
fastest growing software package to ever
reach 10 billion dollars in annual sales
so it's working
meanwhile the push for stem based
education in this country science
technology engineering mathematics is
fierce it's in all of our faces and this
is a colossal mistake since 2009 stem
majors in the United States have
increased by 43 percent while the
humanities have stayed flat our past
president dedicated over a billion
dollars towards STEM education at the
expense of other subjects and our most
our current president recently
redirected 200 million dollars of a
department of education funding into
computer science and CEOs are
continually complaining about an
engineering starved workforce these
campaigns coupled with the undeniable
success of the tech economy I mean let's
face it 7 out of the 10 most valuable
companies in the world by market cap are
technology firms these things create an
assumption that the path of our future
workforce will be dominated by stem I
get it
on paper it makes sense it's tempting
but it's totally overblown it's like the
soccer team that the entire team chases
the ball into the corner because that's
where the ball is
we shouldn't overvalue stem we shouldn't
value the sciences any more than we
value the humanities and there are a
couple reasons number one today's
technologies are incredibly intuitive
the
reason we've been able to recruit from
all disciplines and swivel into
specialized skills is because modern
systems can be manipulated without
writing code they're like Legos easy to
put together easy to learn even easy to
program given the vast amounts of
information that are available for
learning yes
our workforce needs specialized skill
but that skill requires a far less
rigorous and formalized
education than it did in the past number
two the skills that are imperative and
differentiated in a world with intuitive
technology are the skills that help us
to work together as humans where the
hard work is envisioning the end product
and its usefulness which requires
real-world experience and judgment and
historical context what Jeff's story
taught us is that the customer was
focused on the wrong thing it's the
classic case the technology is
struggling to communicate with the
business and the end user and the
business failing to articulate their
needs I see it every day
we are scratching the surface in our
ability as humans to communicate and
invent together and while the sciences
teach us how to build things
it's the humanities that teach us what
to build and why to build them and
they're equally as important and they're
just as hard
it irks me when I hear people treat the
humanities as a lesser path as the
easier path come on the humanities give
us the context of our world they teach
us how to think critically they are
purposely unstruck
while the sciences are perfectly
purposely structured they teach us to
persuade they give us our language which
we used to convert our emotions to
thought in action and they need to be on
equal footing with the sciences and yes
you can hire a bunch of artists and
build a tech company and have an
incredible outcome now I'm not here
today to tell you that stems bad I'm not
here today
to tell you the girl shouldn't code
please and that next bridge I Drive over
or that next elevator we all jump into
let's make sure there's an engineer
behind it but to fall into this paranoia
that our future jobs will be dominated
by stem that's just folly if you have
friends or kids or relatives or
grandchildren or nieces or nephews
encourage them to be whatever they want
to be
the jobs will be there those tech CEOs
that are clamoring for stem grads you
know what they're hiring for Google
Apple Facebook 65% of their open job
opportunities are non-technical
marketers designers project managers
program managers product managers
lawyers HR specialists trainers coaches
sellers buyers on and on these are the
jobs they're hiring for and if there's
one thing that our future workforce
needs and I think we can all agree on
this its diversity but that diversity
shouldn't end with gender or race we
need a diversity of backgrounds and
skills with introverts and extroverts
and leaders and followers that is our
future workforce and the fact that the
technology is getting easier and more
accessible frees that workforce up to
study whatever they damn well please
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]